In a streaming video system, where the server
streams stored audio and video, the server stores
the audio or video files, the client requests
the files and plays them as they download.
It's important to play the data at the
right time. The server can divide the data
into segments and then label each segment with
a time stamp. Indicating the time at which
that particular segment should be played so the
client knows when to play that data. The data
must arrive at the client quickly enough, otherwise the
client can't keep playing. The solution is to have
a client use what's called a playout buffer,
where the client stores data as it arrives from
the server, and plays the data for the user
in a continuous fashion. Thus, data might arrive more
slowly or more quickly from the server, but
as long as the client is playing data out
of the buffer at a continuous rate, the
user sees a smooth playout. A client may typically
wait a few seconds before it starts playing
the stream to allow data to be built up
in this buffer. To account for cases when the
server might have times where it is not sending
at a rate that's sufficient to satisfy the client's playout rate.